But the fact is that the price
that Ukraine
has paid up to now, and will pay
in the future is much,
much greater than the price
that the Russians have paid
and the West is leading
Ukraine down the primrose
path, and the Israelis
are executing a genocide in Gaza.
It's not China's fault
that it wants to be powerful.
So if you get into trouble and you
dial 911, there's nobody at the other...
Hi, this is John Mearsheimer,
and in today's episode,
what I would like to talk about
is an article that appeared in Britain
that was written by Yulia Mendel.
And it's entitled "Zelensky's Strategy
Is National Suicide."
And this article was published
in The Spectator,
which is a British magazine,
on the 15th of September.
That was a week ago today.
And then the day
after she actually gave a speech.
It was done
virtually to the European Parliament
on the same basic themes
that are contained in that article.
Now, who exactly is Yulia Mendel?
She was,
President Zelensky's
first press secretary
between 2019 and 2021.
And as I'm sure everyone knows, the war
in Ukraine
broke out in February of 2022.
So she was not the press secretary
when the war broke out.
She was the press secretary
for the two years before the war.
Nevertheless,
she remained very close to Zelensky
and she was a firm supporter of the war
through 2024.
But then in 2025,
she began to be a real doubter.
She began to think that this war
made no sense,
and she started to criticize the conflict.
And this, of course,
resulted in the article that she wrote
last week in The Spectator and the talk
that she gave to the European Parliament.
Now I want to lay out
exactly what her specific argument is.
She is not arguing
that Ukraine is going to lose the war,
although she believes that's true.
She says the Ukraine has no, quote
unquote, theory of victory.
And it's clear from the piece
that she expects Russia to win the war.
Her argument goes well beyond that.
She's arguing that Ukraine
is actually committing national suicide,
and she's arguing
that Ukraine is going to end up
in a situation where it is
no longer a functioning state.
It is completely dysfunctional
as a result of this war.
I don't think she's arguing, quite wisely,
I might add, that Ukraine
is going to disappear from the map.
I think she recognizes that there will be
a dysfunctional rump state at the end,
but that rump state
will be dysfunctional in the extreme.
And I think that's what she means
by national suicide.
I think that this is
a remarkably controversial argument,
not simply because she's arguing
that Zelensky is responsible
for pushing Ukraine down this road,
but also because of her former position
as his press secretary
and as a staunch supporter of the war.
Up until 2025.
So she's not just any person
off the street.
She's an she's a person
of quite significant prominence,
and she's making
a remarkably controversial argument.
I think the argument
is not only controversial,
but I think it's compelling as well.
I think when you go through
all the different points
that she makes in the piece,
it's quite clear that she's correct
that Ukraine is committing
national suicide.
And what I'd like to do
is go through her argument,
unpack the claims
or the various points that she's making.
And I
think the best way to do
that is to start with a simple framework.
And that framework says that in essence,
there are five parts
to her argument, five dimensions.
One is that
Ukraine is undergoing
a demographic disaster.
Two, that Ukraine is undergoing
an economic disaster.
Three, that Ukraine is undergoing
a territorial disaster.
Four, that it's
undergoing a political disaster.
And finally, number five,
it's undergoing a security disaster.
So to be clear again,
there are five dimensions here
that we want to talk about.
One is the demographic disaster.
Two is the economic disaster.
Three is the territorial disaster
four is the political disaster.
And five is the security disaster.
Let me start
with the demographic disaster,
which in many ways is, I think,
the most powerful part of her argument.
She basically says that
if you look at what's happened to Ukraine
since it got its independence in 1991,
which of course was not that long ago,
its population has halved. Ukraine today
has half the population that it had
when it got its independence in 1991.
She also makes the argument
that half of the existing population
inside of Ukraine is of retirement age.
50% of the population
is of retirement age.
Furthermore,
she makes the point
which I find stunning that
for every one birth in Ukraine these days,
there are four deaths.
Just think about that: four people die
for every one person
who is born in Ukraine.
And then she looks
at the number of young men
who are of conscription age
in Russia and in Ukraine.
And she makes the argument
that there are 4 million men
in Ukraine of conscription age.
And she argues that Russia has ten times
as many people of conscription age.
And of course, one of her
central arguments in this piece,
which is not controversial at all,
is that this is a war of attrition.
In a war of attrition,
the size of your population matters
greatly, and the number of men
you have of conscription age
obviously matters greatly.
And she's arguing
that Russia has ten times as many people
who are of conscription age
as Ukraine does.
Now, I've checked up on her numbers
as best I can.
And I think she's essentially correct
with regard to all those numbers
on population size.
Almost everybody agrees
that Ukraine was about comprised
of about 52 million people
when it got its independence.
Her argument
is that Ukraine now has between
20 and 25 million people.
So you see, if
if you use her upper end number
25 million, 25 million is easily
half of 52 million.
And if you use the number
20 million, it's more than half.
In other words, Ukraine's
population has been cut by more than half.
I think the 25 million number
is a better number to use.
I think if you look at what
demographic demographers
in Ukraine are saying,
they usually put the number in the high 20s
range.
They usually put the number around 28, 29.
And if you look at official government
statistics, the principal minister
of for social policy puts the number
at between 22 and 25.
So again her number is 20 to 25.
And the Minister for Social Policy
puts the number at 22 to 25.
I think 25 is a good number to use.
And if you use the number 25,
which is to say
there are 25 million people
in Ukraine today, then it's quite clear
that that is half the population
that existed in Ukraine in 1991
when it got its independence.
With regard to the claim
that half of the population is
of retirement age,
in other words, half of that
25 million is of retirement age.
I think the number
is probably closer to 45%, but
there's not that much difference
between 45% and 50%.
And on the point that she makes,
which I think again, is quite stunning,
that there are four
Ukrainians dying every
day for every one Ukrainian who is born.
I think that number is correct.
I don't see any evidence that she's wrong
there.
And the same thing is true with her
claim that there are
4 million Ukrainians of draft age,
and there are ten times
as many Russians of draft age.
I would add the caveat, however, that
the Russians don't draft people
and send them into combat
in the way that the Ukrainians do.
But nevertheless,
I think her point about the ten times
greater number of potential
Russian conscripts is correct.
Let me just add some facts
to what she had to say.
Recently, the Polish
Prime Minister, Donald Tusk, said
that the Ukrainians are losing
27,000 soldiers every month.
Either to death or to wounds.
In other words, the number of Ukrainian
casualties on a monthly basis.
He was told by the Ukrainians,
this is what Prime Minister
Tusk of
Poland says he was told by the Ukrainians,
is that Ukraine is losing 27 million
people per month.
And again, that's casualties, not deaths.
It's deaths plus wounded
and I would assume, badly wounded.
Well,
this war has been going on for 54 months.
And if you assume that
there were 27 million,
excuse me, 27,000 casualties
every month, then that would mean
that over the course of these 54 months,
over the course of this war,
the Ukrainians have suffered
1,458,000 casualties.
Now, I think that number is inflated,
because I don't think that Ukraine
has been losing 27,000,
troops every month.
In other words, there haven't been 27,000
casualties every month for this war.
I think the number per month is lower.
I can't tell you exactly
what the number is, but let's just assume
that the Ukrainians have suffered
20,000 casualties
per month,
not 27,000 casualties per month.
Even if the Ukrainians are only suffering
20,000 casualties per month.
That would still be a total of more
than 1 million casualties.
This is a remarkably high number,
and you want to remember that in the month
of July of this year, President Zelensky
said that only 50,000
Ukrainians had died in this war
and 400,000 had been wounded.
So, according to President Zelensky,
the number of casualties in this war
on the Ukrainian side are 450,000
450,000 is a lot less
than the 1.458 million
figure, and even a lot less,
more than half
less than the 1 million figure.
If you assume that there have been
only 20,000 casualties per month.
So you can see the effects of this war
have been stunning.
From a demographic point of view
on Ukraine.
There's one more point that needs to be
made regarding demography.
Almost everybody
who has looked at this problem
believes that Ukraine is going to have a
an extremely difficult time
recovering from this demographic disaster.
In fact,
some argue that it's almost impossible.
First of all,
you have a much smaller population
now than you had before the war started.
Number two, you have an old population,
and number three,
you have a remarkably low
fertility rate inside of Ukraine.
The average
Ukrainian woman basically has 1.0 babies.
And to have replacement rate,
it's essential
that each woman have 2.1 babies.
That's just to maintain
a steady population number.
But again,
Ukrainians are not even close to 2.1.
The number is 1.0.
So most people think
that this demographic disaster
is not going to improve moving forward.
And if anything, Ukraine
is going to continue
to lose significant numbers
of people every year.
And by the way, the Ukrainians are losing
about 600,000 people a year now.
And there's no good reason to
think that that number is going to change
in any significant way moving forward.
The only caveat to this
is that a good number of the people
who have left Ukraine and moved to Europe
may come back,
and that would, in a very important
way, help
mitigate this problem
or ameliorate this problem somewhat.
But the fact is that Ukraine is suffering
a demographic disaster,
and there is little hope
that this situation can be reversed
in the future.
Second, there's the economic disaster.
First of all,
the Russians are wrecking
infrastructure inside of Ukraine.
As Yulia
Mendel points out,
the energy system has been badly damaged.
It's likely to be destroyed
in large part before the winter.
That's likely to have huge
humanitarian consequences
over the course of the winter.
She also points out
that 90% of the storage sites
inside of Ukraine have been destroyed.
And of course, the transportation network
is being torn apart.
The Russians are targeting gas stations
all across Ukraine, but
especially in the western part of Ukraine.
The Russians have shut down the various
Ukrainian ports on the Black Sea.
And in effect,
Ukraine is now a landlocked country.
So with all this wrecked infrastructure,
you basically have a situation
where Ukraine's economy is
incapable of functioning in a way
that other economies in Europe function.
It's become
a completely dysfunctional economy.
And this leads to the second point
that she makes, which is that
Ukraine is now dependent on Western
aid to stay afloat because Ukraine's
economy by itself
can't meet the demands of the war
or the demands of the people,
and can't keep the government afloat.
It depends
to a great extent on aid from the West.
And I would estimate up to now
that the West has given
Ukraine somewhere between 350 billion
and $400 billion in aid.
This is a remarkable number.
Last year,
it was decided that it would be necessary
to keep Ukraine afloat,
to give it about $105 billion,
which could be used
in both 2026 this year and next year,
2027, to pay the bills. And
that basically
meant that you would need
$52 billion this year
for Ukraine and $52
billion next year for Ukraine.
And that money, of course, was allocated.
But what recently happened
is that Ukraine
discovered that it needs 27 million,
billion, 27 billion more dollars
just to make it to the end of this year.
So that $105 billion
that was designed to cover
2026 and 2027 is not sufficient.
You need another $27 billion.
And very important what happened
is that the Europeans began to say
that it is not clear
that we can raise $27 billion.
We've been stretched to the limit
for most,
for the most part, and digging up
another $27 billion on top of the $105
billion that we've already given you,
is probably not possible.
But even if they do come up with the $27
billion, what you see is happening here
is that the money from
the West is drying up.
And of course, President Trump
has made it clear that he has no interest
over the long term of continuing
to sustain
the flow of aid
to Ukraine that we have been giving up to now.
He wants to cut back.
He wants the Europeans to pick up
more of the slack.
He wants the burden of providing
financial aid
to Ukraine,
to fall on the shoulders of the Europeans.
And he wants to get the Americans
out of the business
of supporting the Ukrainians financially.
But the Europeans, of course,
are not in a position to do that.
The Europeans are not, in my opinion,
going to be able to raise
$27 billion more than the $105 billion
they've allocated for 2026 and 2027.
So you see,
when we talk about the economic dimension
of this problem, that what's happened here
is that the infrastructure
in Ukraine has been in large part
destroyed,
therefore its economy has been destroyed,
and therefore it has to depend
to a great extent on Western aid.
And that Western aid is not enough.
And it's beginning to dry up.
Now, one other point on this,
Yulia Mendel points out that
if you look at the debt level
in Ukraine, it's 110%
of gross domestic product, GDP,
110% of gross domestic product is
evidence that economy is deeply indebted
and in deep trouble.
And of course, the IMF has said
explicitly
that this situation is unsustainable
and something has to be done
to restructure the debt.
Good luck with that.
Given the fact that it is
quite clear that the Europeans
and the Americans are going to slow down
in terms
of giving aid to Ukraine moving forward.
Now, the next point I want to talk about
is the territorial disaster
that has taken place in Ukraine.
You want to remember what I've said so far
is that there has been a demographic
disaster,
and there has been an economic disaster.
Now, I want to talk
about the territorial disaster.
And you want to keep in mind,
as I talk about the territorial disaster,
that it is linked to the disaster
that I'm just finishing up with. Now,
regarding the territorial disaster.
Ukraine has already lost
20% of its territory.
The Russians have annexed four oblasts
and they have annexed Crimea.
They've not conquered all the territory
in three of those oblasts,
but nevertheless,
they've annexed four oblasts and Crimea,
and they control about
20% of Ukraine's territory.
That means that Ukraine has lost
a fifth of its territory,
and it has no hope of reconquering
that territory, despite what
one hears in the mainstream media
that 20% is gone.
Now, very importantly,
you want to understand that before
the war, 25% of Ukraine's
GDP was found in that territory,
30% of its
industrial production
was found in that territory.
Here we're talking about the 20%
that Ukraine has lost.
And furthermore, 25% of its population
was located in that territory.
This,
of course, is one of the principal reasons
that Ukraine's population
has shrunk so much,
because that part of the population,
it was located in that eastern
one fifth of Ukrainian territory
that the Russians have now conquered
are no longer counts
as part of the population of Ukraine.
So again,
you see that not only has Ukraine
lost a fifth of its territory,
it's lost territory
that contained industrial
might, that contained GDP
and contained population.
Then to take this
a step further, it's not clear
that Ukraine will not lose more territory.
The Russians make it clear
from time to time
that they are incentivized
to take more territory.
And what is particularly
worrisome from
a Ukrainian point of view
at this point in time
is that the Russians might take Odessa,
and if they take the Odessa Oblast,
that will, in effect permanently
cut Ukraine off from the Black Sea,
and that will have devastating
consequences for the Ukrainian economy
moving forward,
because so much of Ukrainian agricultural
and industrial production
goes out through the Black Sea,
and huge numbers of imports
come in through the Black Sea.
So if the Russians control Odessa
or they take over Odessa
and they annex Odessa, this means
that Ukraine will be permanently
a landlocked country,
which will have devastating
economic consequences.
To go back to the 20% number,
as I've said,
and almost everybody agrees on this,
Ukraine has lost about 20%
of its population,
excuse me, 20% of its territory.
I would
estimate that there's a reasonable chance
that it will end up losing 40%
or 35% of its territory.
It remains to be seen.
But given the direction that the war
is taking, it is clearly possible
that Ukraine will end up losing much more
than just 20% of its territory,
which will have a significant effect
on its GDP moving forward, on its
population size moving forward and on its
industrial production moving forward.
Now, let's talk about
the political dimension of this conflict
and elaborate on why
this is a political disaster.
First of all, it's very clear, as Yulia
Mendel emphasizes that this war
and the continuation of this war, year
after year,
has undermined democracy.
There's great emphasis
placed on censorship
and curtailing free speech
inside of Ukraine.
There is no.
The election that was scheduled
a year ago was deferred,
and there's no evidence there's
going to be an election anytime soon.
And political rights
more generally have been curtailed.
This is hardly surprising
any time a country fights a total war.
And this was true of all of the countries
in World War One, in World War Two.
The government goes to great lengths
to curtail democracy.
You find yourself engaged in
what is sometimes called a total war.
And when you're engaged in a total war,
democracy is almost invariably undermined.
And for sure, the Ukrainians are involved
in in a total war.
This is an existential war for them.
They're fighting for their life,
and they're doing everything they can
to mobilize the country to win this war.
And when that happens, whether it's
Ukraine or Germany or Britain in World War
One or even the United States, democracy
is undermined in very important ways,
which is why you want to minimize
the number of times you fight wars.
And if you do fight wars,
to spend as little time as possible
fighting those wars, because
creating a national security state
and fighting wars all the time,
and especially fighting existential wars,
is bound to undermine democracy.
And unsurprisingly, Ukraine,
which was a flawed democracy
going into the war in 2022,
has seen its democratic institutions
eroded in seriously ways, serious ways.
And this, of course,
will be very difficult to recover from.
One other, very important issue here,
when we talk about what
a political disaster
this war is, has to do with corruption. As
almost everybody knows
from reading the newspaper every day,
there is a huge amount of corruption
inside of Ukraine
and all of this Western aid.
Remember
I was talking about somewhere between 350
to $400 billion
in aid coming into Ukraine.
All of this aid just lends itself
to corruption at the elite level.
And of course, the Ukrainians
have not disappointed us on this front.
There is significant corruption.
So you see, this is this war
has been a political disaster
because of what it means
for democratic institutions
and because of what it means for
jacking up the levels of corruption,
which of course, were high
before the war even started.
I mean, Ukraine was known
as a highly corrupt state
before February 2022,
and that situation has just gotten worse
at the elite level for sure
since the war started.
Excuse me.
Now let me talk about
the security dimension and explain to you
why this has been a security disaster.
And I want to make two major points here.
The first
is that Ukraine, for purposes of security,
wants very much
to become a member of NATO.
And if it can't become a member of NATO,
it wants a security guarantee
from the United States.
It's quite clear.
And Yulia Mendel says this explicitly,
that the question of Ukraine joining
NATO is off the table.
Ukraine is not going to join
NATO, and
it's not going to get a security guarantee
from the United States
or a security guarantee of any consequence
from any European country.
So Ukraine is going to be on its own.
This war, which was fought in large part
so that Ukraine could become
part of NATO, is a failure.
Ukraine is not going to become a part of
NATO.
It's not going to get
a meaningful security guarantee.
And that is to say it's
going to be on its own.
It's going to have to provide
for its own security.
My second major point here,
under the security dimension, is that Ukraine,
is going to end this war
much weaker than when it started the war.
Now, the key point
you want to keep in mind is the two
building blocks of military power.
The two building blocks of military power
are population size.
Number one.
And wealth number two,
to generate military power.
And of course, Ukraine
needs military power to protect itself.
Remember, there's
going to be no membership in NATO.
There's going to be no security guarantee
from the United States
or any other country.
Ukraine is on its own,
so it's going to need a powerful military
or as powerful a military as it can build
to provide for its own security.
But what I'm telling you is
that it's not going to be able
to build a powerful military,
because the two building
blocks of military power
are population size and wealth.
And we talked about population size.
We talked about the demographic disaster
that Ukraine is facing.
And with regard to wealth,
we talked about the economic disaster
that Ukraine is facing.
So you see that
from a security perspective.
Ukraine is in an absolutely horrible,
horrible condition.
It's in an absolutely horrible condition.
So let me just put all the pieces together
and review what I've said to you here
from a demographic point of view.
This is a country that's half the size
it was when it got its independence
in 1991.
And if you look at what's happening
in terms of the birth rate
and the death rate, this is a country
that is continuing to shrink in size.
This is a demographic disaster
that Ukraine is facing.
Furthermore,
it is facing an economic disaster.
Its infrastructure,
its economy has been destroyed.
It's heavily
dependent on support from the West.
And that support is drying up.
Furthermore,
from a territorial point of view,
it's lost 20% of its population.
That population contained
all sorts of wealth, all sorts of people,
all sorts of industrial production.
It's gone.
And it's not clear that 20% will be
all the territory that it loses.
It may lose somewhere in the order
of 35 to 40% of its territory.
The war has been a political disaster.
It's undermined
the democratic institutions
inside of Ukraine,
which were never too strong to begin with.
And furthermore,
it's fueled corruption at the elite level.
And then finally, as we just talked
about at the security level,
this has been a disaster there as well.
Ukraine's not going to join NATO.
It's not going to get
a security guarantee.
And militarily, militarily,
it's going to be weaker moving forward.
Its ability to generate military power
today is much less
than it was in 1991, for sure.
And in 2022,
right before this war started as well.
So this war has been
an unmitigated disaster for Ukraine.
And this,
of course, is why Yulia Mendel is arguing
that Zelensky's continuation of this war
is leading to national suicide.
I think the evidence, when you look at it
carefully, is overwhelming
that she is correct.
Now, I want to conclude
with two final points.
First, I want to
compare this to the situation in Russia.
As you know, I was in Russia
between September 5th and September 12th,
and I spent a lot of time
talking to people and looking around
and assessing
what the situation is in Russia.
And when I read Mendel's piece,
I couldn't help
but think about the contrast with Russia.
The situation in Russia
is the polar opposite
of the situation in Ukraine.
I don't want to argue
that Russia hasn't suffered
from the war because it certainly has.
But if you think about it carefully,
the situation
is just fundamentally different in Russia
than it is in Ukraine today.
Now, Russia
clearly has a demographic problem
independent of the war,
similar to the demographic problem
that Ukraine had even before the war
started.
Both of these countries
had a demographic problem
before the war, for sure.
But what's happened with the Russians
is they have conquered
a huge swath of territory in Ukraine.
And those people
in that swath of territory
who were previously
Ukrainians have now become Russians.
So as a result of this war,
the Russian population
has increased significantly in size.
Furthermore, in terms of territory,
Ukraine has lost 20% of its territory.
Well, who has captured that territory?
The Russians have captured that territory.
So the Russians have gained territory
and gained population
as a result of this war.
And in terms of their security, remember,
I argue that
this war is a security disaster
for Ukraine.
It has not been a security disaster
for Russia.
Even if Russia wins an ugly victory
and Russia pays a price
for fighting this war.
The fact is that militarily,
Russia is in much better shape
today than it was
when the war started in February 2022.
The Russian army is a much more formidable
instrument today than it was in 2022.
And furthermore, Ukraine
is much weaker today than it was in 2022.
If we were to review
what has happened in each
year of this war, what you would see
is that the Ukrainians did very well
against the Russians in 2022.
2022 was the high water
mark for the Ukrainians.
And then in 2023, they launched a major
offensive in June of that year.
And the reason they launched
that major offensive is
they thought that they could effectively
knock the Russians out of the war,
or at least do serious
damage to the Russian military
and Russia's strategic position
in eastern Ukraine.
So in 2023, the Ukrainians felt
they were on a roll.
They had control
of the commanding heights.
But if you look at what happened
that year, towards
the end of that year, 2023,
what happened in 2024,
what happened in 2025,
and where we are in 2026.
You see that Ukraine's security situation
has significantly deteriorated
and Russia's
security situation has improved markedly.
All of this is a way of saying that
Russia is in much better shape today
than it was in 2022.
And again,
I don't want to make light of the fact
that the Russians have suffered
as a result of this war,
that many Russians have died
or been badly wounded,
just as many Ukrainians have died
or have been badly wounded.
But the fact is that the price
that Ukraine has paid up to now,
and will pay in
the future is much, much greater
than the price that the Russians have paid
and will pay moving forward.
My final point, and this is a point
that Mendel makes very clearly,
is it's not just Zelensky
who is responsible
for leading Ukraine toward
national suicide.
It's the West as well.
And as I'm sure almost all viewers know,
the West
has often talked about using Ukraine
as a battering ram
to weaken Russia.
And of course, as Mendel makes clear,
it is the Ukrainians, not the Europeans
nor the
Americans, who are paying the price
for fighting this war
against the Russians.
And she's actually very angry.
And you can see this both in her article
that she wrote in the Weekly Standard
and also in her speech
before the European Parliament.
That was the day after her
article appeared
that she spoke
to the European Parliament.
She talks about people
in the comfortable West.
That's her rhetoric,
people in the comfortable West.
She makes it clear
that she thinks that people in the West,
who are not paying the price
of having to fight against the Russians,
are very comfortable
making the argument that Ukraine
should pay the blood price here.
And this makes her very angry.
And she has this one line
that sticks in my head, which says
that Western political elites would rather
see Russia burn than Ukraine saved.
Think about that.
Western political elites
would rather see Russia burn
than Ukraine saved.
And her point is
that Ukraine is not going to be saved.
It is committing national suicide.
And as I say,
this is a controversial argument for sure.
But I think if you look carefully
at those five dimensions
that I've outlined, what you see is that
Ukraine is facing a disaster
on every one of them.
And this war, in the end, is a complete
catastrophe for Ukraine.
On that sad note,
let me conclude this episode
and wish everybody Godspeed.
Thank you.